news daily from science mission the
major genetic cause of frontotemporal
dementia and ALS is a geforce e to
repeat expansion in c 9 / f 72
scientists developed a mouse model by
expressing g4 c 266 repeats throughout
the mouth central system which after six
months developed nuclear RNA force I
inclusions of dipeptide repeat proteins
as well as tdp-43 pathology these mouse
brains also exhibited cortical neuron
and cerebellar Purkinje cell loss as
doble haces decreased weight and
developed behavioral abnormalities
similar to clinical symptoms of ALS
patients next Werner syndrome is a
premature aging disorder caused by
verner protein deficiency scientists
generate a human Werner syndrome model
in human embryonic stem cells which when
differentiated to mesenchymal stem cells
recapitulates features of premature
cellular aging they also show that
Werner associates with heterochromatin
proteins and when one of them was
knocked in as catalytically inactive
protein mach3 capitalist heterochromatin
marks accelerated cellular senescence
resembling Warner deficient cells next
it is generally assumed that mRNAs under
growing translations are protected from
decay authors demonstrate that enzyme
degrading mRNA follows closely behind
the ribosome passing at set points along
the mRNA usually after each group of
three nucleotides the section of code
that relates to one amino acid
researchers believe that this shows the
enzyme passing while transition goes on
allowing the ribosome to do its work and
move on before starting to degrade the
mRNA previously protected by the
resume for more news visitors as WWE
science mission calm and science mission
Facebook page thanks for watching